[Musik]
eigentlich soll man von dieser
brandneuen aussichtsplattform zwischen
dem hessischen heppenheim und lorsch
einen vorzüglichen blick in ein
naturschutzgebiet haben hat man aber
nicht denn die plattform ist nur
schlappe 80 zentimeter hoch und steht
nicht oben auf dem damm sondern knapp
unterhalb die folge man kann nicht über
den deich gucken eine aussichtsplattform
mit aussicht auf gras für 30.000 euro
ich finde meter höher wäre besser
gewesen da die nummer kleiner
also ich würde sagen wenn dann sollte
man das konzipieren planen ja ansonsten
ergibt das keinen sinn weil im endeffekt
ist es jetzt gerade ein bisschen
geldverschwendung ich bin ja nicht der
größte schotten media 75 ich kann gerade
mal so über den damm schauen dabei gibt
es hier auf der weschnitz insel viel zu
sehen störche milano und co fühlen sich
pudelwohl und damit die nicht mehr von
menschen gestört werden wurde das
naturschutzgebiet für spaziergänger und
radfahrer gesperrt
die sollen jetzt als ausgleich von oben
in die natur gucken dürfen nur von oben
kann hier keine rede sein denn es fehlen
gut und gerne zwei meter höhe ein
richtiger aussicht hätte man vom dach
vor jahrzehnten hat man es besser
gemacht denn der alte hans ludwig turm
auf der anderen seite ist fast zehn
meter hoch da sieht man wirklich was
trotzdem findet man beim gewässer
verband bergstraße die niedrige
aussichtsplattform hoch genug
das ding ist nicht zu niedrig es wurde
nie etwas anderes war nie etwas anderes
vorgesehen als eine aussichtsplattform
dorthin zu stellen das ganze projekt hat
im vorfeld eine sehr breite öffentliche
bearbeitung erhalten wenn man vor der
plattform steht sieht man genau so viel
als würde man aus der hütte ausblicken
warum also nicht einen anständigen
aussichtsturm bayerisch ist mit
sicherheit kein problem baulich ist gar
nichts ein problem ist eine frage des
geldes natürlich ein hoher turm wäre
auch baulich möglich gewesen hätte mit
sicherheit ganz andere finanzielle
dimensionen auch gehabt
also baut man lieber etwas was überhaupt
keinen sinn macht
es ist halt typisch die planer die an
irgendeinem tollen tisch sitzen und
irgendwas entwerfen und sich überhaupt
keine gedanken machen wie es da vor ort
eigentlich wirklich aussieht wenn das
hörbar wird schöner aussicht da kennt
man viel mehr anfangen
und so ist was gebaut wurde und wird
korsika genutzt dabei wäre schon viel
geholfen wenn man die plattform einfach
oben auf den damm gesetzt hätte aber auf
die idee ist in lorch niemand gekommen